Back live for the day.
The whole day.
I'm trying to think what I want to do
from here, honestly.
Maybe I should provide a little bit of
context.
Yeah, I think I'll take the first little
bit of today and just sort of talk
through some of my thoughts on uh what
I've been doing for the last bit and
where we can go from here.
So, I just ran this experiment like
literally in the last hour.
It's not entirely new. So it is a fair
bit more stable though than what I had
before.
And uh what this is is doing
online RL but keeping just a tiny little
bit of off policy data around tiny
little replay buffer.
And uh the the thing with this task is
the first chunk of this problem is a
really sparse exploration problem
and it takes five billion steps for it
to learn anything normally.
And this is like a pretty aggressively
optimized benchmark as well.
So just a little bit of off policy data
which is going to end up being like the
best trajectory segments.
You get this massive massive
improvement.
Hey, Tim.
Now, this is going to take absolutely
forever to run, and I don't know if this
actually gets us to a better place or if
it just learns faster.
Um,
but I suppose we have a couple ideas to
look at.
So, option one here, right, is
we kind of just assume Whoops. Why is my
mic peeking?
this better? Yeah. So, option one here
is we kind of just assume that we're
going to be able to
not play by the rules and use offpaul
data with onpaul RL.
Option two is we go heavily into world
models
yesterday linked a thing which I think I
think I saw the thing that you linked
um it seemed like they had correct me if
I'm wrong
don't they have Isn't this supposed to
be for like explicitly mixed expert data
And with online RL, it's not just like
I pretty much would like you to be able
to use whatever data.
And what they do is they constrain they
do like a they add a constraint that you
stay close to the actions
uh from the actual offline data I think.
Yeah.
But like I'm not So giving it expert
data is one thing.
Um that's like a problem.
I kind of was using that as a motivating
example of like where a lot of
algorithms fail.
In my mind, you should just you should
be able to have an algorithm that can do
sample reuse that if you give it a ton
of data and like not very much compute
will do as well as standard onpaul RL
and if you give it a ton of
um a ton of compute and not much data it
will do like as well as world models but
then smooth in between.
The big problem right now in my mind is
that
there's this big compute gap where like
you either use a ton of additional
compute to have more sample efficiency
or you use a ton of data and get compute
efficiency and there's no reasonable
midpoints.
I can't see why it's so hard. So the
reason that this is hard Tim is that if
you look at the offpaul methods they do
like 200fold sample reuse oftent times
right um they do like a huge amount of
sample reuse
and then the onpaul methods are like
zero or like 1x sample reuse maybe 4x
sample reuse
there's no like clear progression where
you can go to 8x to 16x X like it just
doesn't work.
Why do you need so much? Well, what you
would like to have, right, is you'd like
to have a method where
you can spend more compute to learn more
out of limited data.
So, I mean, here's the motivation,
right? Show you
Um,
this is um 100,000
frames of Atari, like two hours of data.
Very tiny amount of data, right?
This is like better than human level
sample efficiency.
Well, I'm trying to figure out what to
do at the moment more than anything.
him.
They do search, right? But do you see
the point? The point is, and it's it's
not search on the end. It's all learned.
It's a learned model.
So, they're spending more compute
to get like near human level well
actually like human level sample
efficiency.
Right. But do you see the problem? Like
I can't take this method and give it as
much data as I give puffer lib and like
less compute and have it still work.
You either have a ton of compute and you
get good sample efficiency or you have a
ton of data and you get good compute
efficiency, but there's not really
anything in between.
like as soon as you train a world model
like there's a fixed cost like there's a
big cost to training a world model and
then if you look at like off policy
where you're not training a world model
that also can improve sample efficiency
but the algorithms are fundamentally
weaker to the point that you'd need to
spend more compute to get them to par
and performance and then if you spend
even more compute then they better.
Problem is this does not enable.
This data reuse thing is cool,
but it's a really weak version of it,
honestly.
I mean, pretty much what this result
just shows you is like, yeah, you need
to be able to reuse samples.
Okay, I guess what here's what we can
look at this graph as, right?
Independent of the method that I used to
do this.
This says, and this is not even using
any more compute, by the way. This is
literally compute matched.
So this says if you can use if you can
reuse samples
uh especially on like hard environments
right there's a huge huge gap in what
you can do if you can reuse samples.
This is like very strong motivation for
sample reuse.
But the specific form of sample use I
have here is very weak. This is like a
very weak form of it.
How much compute does dreamer spend on
its world model?
Wait, maybe maybe that's a good thing to
look at.
Someone's enabling search.
Yeah. Well, I guess then the question is
how
So this is
Huffer
And then this is probably like,
you know,
This is like puffer.
If I
optimized for sample efficiency, I
could get it to here. And then this is
dead space.
Does world model take so much? I don't
think so. That's the problem.
Let's look at it though.
Why worry about compute instead of wall
clock?
So,
I mean, I get this with clients all the
time. Um
the difference between these two things
is if you hand me a slow simulator right
now with puffer uh what I have to do is
I have to make your simulator fast
and then I apply puffer which works very
well for a lot of problems
but there's some problems that I can't
make your simulator fast enough for.
And basically, there's no way for me to
just take your problem, spend like spin
up a thousand GPUs and solve it for you
right now.
Uh, PO is very compute efficient if
Well, I see what you mean. Yeah. base PO
is not large like large batch PO is if
you do it well like Puffer's
implementation is the thing though is
it's actually it's a lot easier to make
the world model stuff computationally
efficient like you have to really mess
up the engineering to make this super
Hello.
Actually, they did give us this, didn't
they?
I mean, the replay ratios are not even
huge on this. It's just the models that
are.
have one
interesting as a replay ratio of one
actually. That's very interesting, isn't
it?
You can't use off policy data with PO.
Yeah, I understand why you can't do it
in theory. Um, counterpoint.
Yeah. So, I've tried something exactly
like that, Carlos. Your value function
gets stale,
cuz you don't have a way to train the uh
the value function if you just do
behavioral cloning.
I've tried like several different
versions of that actually.
Why is this thing so bloody good on
paper and then it just sucks when you
try to do anything like this?
I mean, I guess we aren't doing pixel
reconstruction.
What if the actor and the critic share
the same parameters? Then it's even
worse because uh not only is the actor
the is the critic getting stale, but uh
you're not you don't even have like any
reasonable loss to prevent the value
from like drifting completely.
How did you do this run?
Yeah, so I just kept around um I kept
around like a very small
like literally like a was it like an
eighth of a batch or something? just a
very small amount of high advantage
trajectory segments
and I just train on the like I keep
those in this in the training buffer for
sampling. So literally just keeping
around a very small amount of data. Huh?
Yes, you do. You just do it anyways and
you only use a very small amount of
replay data.
it means that you have you have data
that's in a replay buffer that's like
very stale.
So you're not only training on data that
is from like roughly the current policy
they have 100. I thought they had like a
1 mil
your world model approach look if you
try to pawn with full RGB frame buffer
instead of eight OBS.
Why would why would me having a very low
obs like that should make it easier,
shouldn't it?
It should be easier to learn a good
world model. Huh?
it's difficult as well to evaluate
because like
basically once you step outside of the
the high data regime of puffer
like all your experiments start taking
days and I'm not doing research where my
experiments take days. That's just a
complete waste of life.
When it says higher replay ratios.
those.
to join the Discord.
Discord/puffer.
I guess we should just like go to
and bootstrap a squad versus squad drone
fight
in Pi Bullet.
Probably your problem is that the MV is
slow. That would be my guess. If you
were using Pi Bullet,
we have drone M and like fighter M where
they run millions of steps per second.
A lot easier to do stuff there. Like not
even particularly difficult to get like
that type of stuff to work. The NV is
just fast.
I mean, I think I have to just go back
to the
I think I just have to go back to the
dreamer crap, right?
This paper just actually drives me
insane.
I wonder if it's time to start from
their code.
Value losses MSE. What if you
re-evaluate and recomputee the
advantage?
the um
so the whole point of training the
advantage right the entire value is that
the rewards come from the policy
like it's actually a way stronger on
policy assumption for training the value
function than for training the policy.
Like if you actually kind of squint at
the math for uh policy gradients,
you don't really need the data to come
from the policy at all. Um if you look
at the value function though, the value
function update, you absolutely need it
to come from the policy.
Rewards are a function
of the state.
But you care about transition like
transition to reward not state to
reward, right?
Okay, I mean at least this code is not
batshit
Save good data. Behavioral cloning.
Refresh value. Repeat.
You can you can recomputee the
advantage. And I do recomputee the
advantage. I don't think you can
I don't think you can keep training the
value function though cuz the whole
point of the RL is that it takes the
policy off of the current reward segment
data.
You're not doing off policy really
Carlos.
It depends what you mean by save good
data and how long you keep it around.
I'm gonna try something with this repo.
Honestly, let me just fork it.
I kind of want to just bind this to some
puffs and see if it does anything.
Maybe
maybe
I don't understand how this is the state
of packaging.
So ass.
I just make an M specifically for Yes.
I think we just start going through this
and simplifying.
I don't really know what else we can do
for this
other than um
we'll go find whatever the command is
we're going to want to Done.
trying to catch up with talking to a
friend. I don't know why we open sort
and sampling is good. We suggested
something like
the adjacent avantage weighted
regression.
Yeah. So the uh the sketchy thing with
advantage weighted regression is
uh do you notice that the paper does
like 200fold sample reuse
like literally all of dreamer is less
sample reuse than that.
Most of it is.
I suppose I didn't try the weighted
exponential
for advantage. That's the about about
the only thing I didn't try.
Hey, boxing.
I'm working on stuff as usual.
Yeah, I'm working off of um I'm trying
to get an existing dreamer repo to run
on Puffer just to see if it like
magically breaks somehow
Puffer just is not set up at all for
this thing.
Is this even used for
Hello.
Welcome.
I'm pretty much just trying to retrofit
Puffer onto this mess.
Yeah, teammates would be pretty easy
to make.
The problem is that there really aren't
any memory M's in RL.
Like that's not even a pure memory end
RL because everything in RL is uh it's
entangled with credit assignment as
well, right?
I like that your enjoyable places are
Paris or in a forest.
Have you been to Paris? It's not that
great.
I don't know. For whatever reason, a lot
of Americans
think like Europe is this magical place
where everything is All right.
food was good. I don't know. I I
honestly
it's not anywhere near the top of my
list for even That
That should be biased.
That's funny.
Move this mic a little bit. I can't
freaking see this monitor, do I?
the Americans got
the banter and then go to Europe.
Yeah, that's that's pretty much it.
I mean Europe's if you if you're looking
at cities like most of Europe cities are
nicer. You get nice cities and like zero
social mobility and opportunity.
Where you think all the research is
coming from
Okay. So, uh
this is running at least.
Yeah. And 100K is like below entry level
for like any half decent software in the
US. So like there you go.
Yeah, American suburbs are really nice
and uh rural areas.
Not public labs. No, at labs like if
you're working at a lab or like anything
government, you're getting paid nothing.
But like most of the jobs in the US,
it's not public sector.
Yeah, I don't think I'm physically
capable of taking
like just taking a month off.
I don't know. It would kind of be nice
to work five days a week instead of six,
but uh I get so much less done
this is model based
in model errors.
is eat sur.
All right, I'll have to see this. Oh,
wait. Is this the same Lucas I'm
thinking of?
I'm going to have to read this later
though. I don't have the mental to like
I've kind of like all mathed out myself.
What about Lucas? It's probably a
different Lucas
Puffer dashboard has spoiled me. Yeah.
Look, as soon as I figure out this
research problem, I can actually
optimize the crap out of everything and
make Puffer way nicer. But this is just
driving me insane.
Well, I guess I don't have the sample
reuse cranked up,
but still. I mean, so far this thing has
spent 10 minutes of GPU time to sit here
and do nothing.
See you boxing.
So literally even the uh the reference
implementation so are.
I guess we'll let it run a little longer
here, right? But like
Uh, okay. That's starting to get real
data, I suppose,
I'm pretty sure I set this up correctly.
There are a couple quirks with puffer
you have to be careful of, but I think
that it's correct.
I don't know why the eval return is
still so low.
Where the heck is the actual code for
this thing? Like
Okay, now it's actually getting to the
eval return.
So, you use 20 minutes or so of compute
going to be
Can I work with this from here?
I guess I technically can work with
this, right?
Well, I guess it depends on if this
actually solves
if this actually solves the task in like
a reasonable number of steps.
Then at least like I can work with this
and I can just start deleting all the
other crap out of this repo.
Um
I probably do want to have at least one
of the original tasks to make sure I
don't break anything.
I'll just have to like actually
understand this repo, right?
It is odd that this is
well I mean maybe it's not odd that it's
like few hundred,000 frames then because
I don't have the same sample reuse
ratio.
So they literally use
like three GPU hours on 100k frames of
Atari, huh?
That's nuts.
Like bat [ __ ] Crazy.
It be determined whether this is
impressive.
So confused as to how this works.
Like no code in here.
Uh, all the computes going into the
world model pretty much already. I'm
pretty sure. So, I don't think so.
I think basically all the compute's
already going into that.
thing doesn't seem to be solving yet
though, right?
Bothers me.
Yeah, it's like it's learned something
but it's not
weird.
Very weird.
if this is even going to make sense
without having image OBS.
Yeah, I know. Like they have their own
image ops as well. Um,
I'm just like not willing to accept that
it's really this Stupid.
still not working out of the box on my
thing.
Yeah, this is perverse. How long this
takes?
What's the difference in model size?
I mean, this is it needs to have this
many parameters because it's uh it's
doing image modeling, right?
Maybe we can try. We'll go back to my
version.
What is the scaling with model size?
see the model size scaling.
scales better with the replay than with
the model size. One of these
there's a better way of implementing
this replay ratio thing, right?
I guess the the best thing that I've
seen so far then given that literally
even this is not really working on uh
this is not even working
I think we go back to my
my implementation
and we try to go from that angle.
I mean, if this had just like insta
worked, it would have been a different
story. It's like, oh, okay, I'm dumb. I
just implemented [ __ ] wrong.
Um,
I mean, this is just like yet another
piece of evidence that no, it's not just
as good as it uh it seems on paper,
right?
I'm also sick of staring and like
waiting at this stupidly slow thing. I'm
use the restroom real quick. Um, time is
this 12.
Make some coffee.
I'm going to go make some coffee. I'm
going to take a few minutes and then I
think we're going to do from my section
of uh the modelbased stuff
at least for a little bit today.
And then if that doesn't work, I really
I really just don't know.
Um
I'm like not satisfied at all with
having
a very complicated, very janky algorithm
that needs like 100x the wall clock
time.
But
so obnoxious.
It needs reconstruction gradients.
So it needs reconstruction gradients.
It's unclear whether or not you those
need to be image reconstruction
gradients.
Let me go make myself some coffee,
folks. I'll be back. Yeah. And this is
finished training. And look at that.
Literally random perf [ __ ] algorithm.
Okay.
Did any of your world model twang stuff
work?
Don't get me wrong, it's good, right?
Oh, actually, wait. Let me see.
Yeah, we'll let this experiment just do
its thing. This is actually
We'll just depend on it. We'll have to
let this whole thing just run.
I mean, this is a crazy
crazy gap, right?
Puffer li.
Well, it's not the best for it, but it's
like
it's be like it's either you use puffer
lib or you're competent and you write
your own thing, right?
I guess clean RL. You can hack a clean
RL script. That's like the other simple
thing. I wouldn't like go use one of the
big horrible libraries.
Yan Lun says world models need to be
energy based. Yan Lun's burned a lot of
his credibility.
At the very least, I'm no longer going
to just like
pay attention just cuz he like just cuz
he says a thing.
It's crazy to me that this like slowass
demo is still 200 times faster than the
dreamer code we just played with.
2048 * 16
that's 32k.
Maybe you just want the data to come in
way slower, right?
moved. Walker
boiler to F. RK4.
huh? How the hell did you implement it?
RK short. Like, both of those seem slow
to me.
Are you just doing a ton of iterations?
Yeah, I think that if you you need to do
some balancing, right, to like actually
see how much error there is with the
very like the different methods. My
guess is you're going to be able to do
larger steps or fewer steps or something
in order to compensate.
A uh quadriped sim should be at like
millions.
There's no way that a I refuse to
believe a quadriped sim has to be slow.
There's no way it's 200 physics subst
steps needed.
No freaking way.
go actually like evaluate the errors
that are involved in your calcs and base
the number of steps on that or it
doesn't have to be a fixed number of
steps, right? You can do like uh
should be like a certain threshold cut
off.
A lot of my job in RL is telling people
writing Sims who are like, "No, it's
very complicated. Sim has to be very
slow in order to be very accurate. It's
just nah, make it fast."
I you know I hear what you're saying,
but can you just make it fast.
There's no way you need to do this much,
right?
Like this.
Even one and one should be fine here.
Right
there. That'll get us like some decent
perf.
better.
Uh, episode length cannot possibly be
five.
[Music]
That's fine.
You know, I'm not I'm not understanding
this. You have a massive entropy
coefficient and it's still zero.
I mean, that's Pong doing something in a
few hundredk steps.
I mean, this is kind of good enough to
start automating a little bit, right?
What's happened so far?
We tried uh one of the like actual
reference implementations for Dreamer
and it sucked. So, I went back to my own
implementation and I have I got Pong to
like start learning stuff pretty quick.
There's a lot of instability and such,
but
think that we can probably do something
reasonable about this.
And there you go.
Okay.
It would give me so much amusement if we
just end up doing our own thing and
winning.
Not bad. One minute experiments
is uh decent enough.
Learning across M. I don't think that
makes fundamental sense for a lot of
these
All right. So,
this does give us
this gives us a different way to control
to control the learning, right?
This basically lets us edit the stream
rate of our data.
I actually could probably come up with a
decent algorithm out of this, you know,
data comes in at a fixed rate.
You do online RL.
You train your world model.
If the world model errors below a
certain threshold,
then you do RL on the world model.
It kind of depends if I can get
something to be like reasonable out of
this here. Let's go pull up the uh the
latest the sweep and such. Right.
It's like getting more and more
aggressive about freaking updates.
Stupid Windows
whiteboard. The idea, it's not
complicated enough to be worth
whiteboarding. It's just like you could
basically decide to only use the uh the
world model like to only use apply RL to
the world model when the error is below
a certain threshold or something.
So you could just mix online RL.
Now the thing is that the world model is
usually pretty chunky. So like
you're still going to have the overhead
of training the world model even if
you're not using it which really isn't
All right.
Yeah,
that bit's kind of tough.
Okay. So, I mean this will do some
experiments, right?
I basically just rate limited the data,
right?
So you get little batches of
observations coming in.
You do hardware efficient
world model training and world model RL.
still doing reconstruction while on OBS.
Uh, yes, Spencer, because
the Z toz loss, I think, is actually
harder to learn.
You're actually probably right though
that I should have
I should probably see what that does.
So, I would like to actually not have to
do OBS reconstruction.
but I think that the OBS reconstruction
is easier to learn for the simple tasks
to start with.
I kind of So, Spencer, I kind of just
want to if I can get something that's
like decent enough here and that's like
more sample efficient than base puffer
and like the experiments run in a few
minutes,
then
the key source of error in this whole
approach is just the world model, right?
So like if we can get the world model to
just learn better with less data or
faster or whatever then this starts
being better and better of an idea.
It depends on the structure of the ops
as well. Like think of breakout where
each of those is like a specific brick.
It's kind of a weird thing
like very sparse changes.
A lot of the image m have like a much
smoother
change.
I did actually get So this is I got two
things. Spencer, I don't know if you've
seen. So, this is 1 million steps of
Pong with very unoptimized hypers. So,
like you actually start to get some
learning out of Pong in uh under two
minutes and less than a million steps.
And then the other thing I did, and this
one's pretty cool. Do you see the
Twitter post?
We have at least what I would call good
motivation for doing this.
Look at this.
That's neural MMO 3.
So, well, cuz you didn't understand cuz
I didn't post the full details of it,
right? I kind of just vague posted a
thing, but let me show you.
Okay. So, here's soda on.
Where is it?
And then this is
this is what happens if you just ignore
all reasoning and you just store like
I think it's like a fifth like a quarter
of a mini batch no an eighth of a mini
batch of high advantage segments. So you
basically have a very very small replay
buffer.
So almost all the data is on Paul but a
little tiny bit of off-paul data without
corrections
and you get this gigantic difference
immediately without even retuning hypers
or anything.
So this is 5 billion steps before neural
MMO starts to learn anything.
Starts learning instantly.
now. Whether or not this h like this
helps long term, I don't know. But like
at the very least, this is a pretty
solid motivating
use case cuz this is like the dumbest
possible sample reuse, right? This is
like the dumbest possible sample reuse
and it does this.
Uh if we could I'd say Jess if we can
get the world models to learn faster
then it makes a lot more sense to be
using them more.
My goal is like
my goal with all of this is very very
simple. Um
I guess technically there's a separate
thing of just like sample reuse for the
sake of sample reuse which is good. But
my main goal with all of this is to just
be able to spend more compute or spend
more data. So turn the knob either way
and have one algorithm that smoothly
does both of these regimes.
Is there actually any good stuff on
world model architectures?
Oh, actually I of
I uh I know Lewis who is doing a world
model startup. So, let's just go ask
him.
Wait, what poll?
Think there's a way to predict how
complex an environment would be.
how complex and the best metric we have
of environment complexity is um
compute investment required to learn it
right with an optimized model
see that plot with different sizes of
the buffer yeah so Carlos if you make
the buffer much bigger it collapses
on at least I didn't try that on neural
MMO but on simpler tasks if you give it
too much offpaul data you collapse
Is there a white paper on this? Yes,
there is.
Thank you.
This is what I was looking for.
A lot like you and what he talks about
streamer.
Wait, I sound like Janager or I sound
like Yan Lun.
I think I'd take the Yan.
God damn, that's a tough one.
I think I'd take the Yan Lun one,
honestly.
Yeah. So, Danager is the Wartley is the
um the dreamer guy and
there's a pretty big problem with the
quality of the science in that paper.
I mean, you wouldn't hear me say a damn
word against uh any of it if if I just
had implemented stuff and it worked or
like if any of the previous studies I
had done had like just worked, right?
Does anybody know where the latence are
in this paper? This like giant report
Yeah, please no. I will uh I will have
to be committing suku
insta demonetized if uh
any of these platforms have auto
translate.
Jesus,
I will not take that comparison. Thank
you.
Work is about as far diametrically
opposed as possible. I have really nice
code that actually works and really
shitty write-ups on everything. He has
really crap code that doesn't work and
really nice writeups on everything.
All right, I'm I'm half exhausted here.
Does anybody know where the uh the
latence are in this thing?
Don't know if I dare just type this into
Grock.
I really just need to know like the
latence
like the way that like latent are done.
Well,
I could go look at the original world
model paper
Uh this is not what I meant.
So Jess, I meant the the actual like
what is the mathematical representation
of the latent? Is it like a
multicategorical? Is it Gaussian? Like
what what are they actually doing as
their like low dim
low dim representation.
Yeah. So this is what I mean by the
latence.
I think this paper is missing.
It's like missing good ablations, right?
Yeah.
Annoying.
Okay. Look at this. You see we're making
progress. So, this will actually
potentially get us a uh a good starting
point and then we'll be able to do some
architecture work, right?
I mean, that's a million steps for uh
up to what is this like 10 or whatever
uh 12 score on breakout. I mean on Pong
I mean, you see how little I use
language models in my stuff. I basically
use language models as a crutch for my
bad math. And that's not because the
language models are good. It's just cuz
I'm really bad at it.
I'm not under any impression that it's
like, oh yeah, I don't even need to know
any math because I can just ask the
language model. It's like just as stupid
as the like, I don't need to know how to
code properly. Ask a language model.
So here it is train VAE
and then train
this is a little bit different though
because the world model,
they train the world model first, right?
which doesn't work in general. This
works on easy ends,
I think. But Dreamer does them both
jointly, right?
was it Dreamer V2 that introduced the
categorical Well,
the uh the original paper does not have
applications on hard environments.
The original world model paper does not.
Action conditioned. What?
311's Atari. Oh, you mean for three?
Yeah.
If I do the rewards for reaching
targets,
moving towards them, I could add a
controller to the M.
Wait, use water to walk it around.
If I do rewards for reaching targets
and moving towards them,
um, it's always a good idea to have your
environments human playable.
It's tough in the control case because
you have to actually do like a classic
control benchmark or some [ __ ]
I guess it depends, right?
Cuz if you like if the reward is just
like face target, reach target or
whatever, you could basically map the
last controls to just adjusting the
target and then have the learn policy
basically just carry it out. That would
be cool.
apparently this discrete latent
matters a lot
latent space is a dense grid of patch
embeddings.
Okay, thank you Jess. Yeah, that
actually helps. So what that basically
tells me is that the uh the
representation they use is specific to
images which is limiting whereas the one
that I uh I'm looking at here is not.
That's actually good to know.
Let me see how different this thing
actually is.
I mean the original is pretty simple,
right? I can do
this thing. I can do
do you use the samples?
Do you ever release code for this?
All right. All right. So, you get a
sample from the world model
instead of an obs.
Whereas this is actually
it's actually pretty tricky to come up
with uh
a good version of this because
as soon as you start giving the actor
latence,
you have to start worrying about like
the rate at which you're training each
of these.
and they totally punt on this problem as
well because they have a pre-trained
VAE.
actually. Does anybody know
are there any good world model papers
that don't rely on image gradients?
Is that a thing?
and go back and look at like Mr. Q and
what they did.
any continuous embedding vector.
If it's any continuous embedding vector,
you still have to be able to sample from
it, right?
Like the distribution matters.
These guys do separate reward and
dynamics learning.
Okay, but this is a very different
algorithm
I guess. Are there any world model paper
that actually
doesn't depend on the reconstruction
loss?
Whatever reason, Dreamer really, really
depends on that reconstruction loss.
I mean, if you include search, you can,
right?
I wonder why that is
the case.
I mean, I guess we can sort of work
towards
something like this
cuz here they don't need to do they
don't need to do reconstruction, right?
Yeah, they don't need to do
reconstruction.
I really don't trust that Dreamer just
doesn't do crap on Breakout.
Weird.
the uh
yeah the search components very tough.
Yeah, this thing is really slow though.
2.7 hours per 100k.
I think it's just going to be let this
tune a little bit.
Um, and then we're going to do
just like some real quick ablations on
the world model today.
We'll try like we'll try the latent,
try like a few different things.
Funny that this run did
better than anything else so far.
I could just take this one
as my uh my starting point, right?
I go use the restroom, walk around a
minute, and if there's nothing better,
we'll just take that one.
Be back.
You can add filtering at the trajectory
level. That's a quite different thing
though.
Oh, hang on. We just got a better one.
Well, now I'm not going to kill it
instantly, right?
I think if there's anything else I can
try to figure out in the meantime,
we sort of think about the compute.
I think it's likely that if we have a
reconstruction loss,
then the world model has to be a lot
bigger than the actor, right?
If we don't have a reconstruction loss,
it probably doesn't need to be.
At least Dreamer really needs the
reconstruction loss, though.
What do we think the odds are that it's
fundamental versus just like a really
poorly controlled
baseline? And I mean, they've seen it in
every version of Dreamers, the thing,
but it's probably just the same damn
code repo,
like touched up for three generations.
I do kind of wonder if like if you
actually went and reuned everything,
right?
Is it possible that uh it just works
without the image reconstruction?
I've always liked the M0 style
bit of it.
okay so there's like one practical
annoyance here
right which is if you don't do
reconstruction you have to have a shared
architecture
and like I'd really prefer to not have
to have the world model and agent be
shared.
>> Well, because like you're just not going
to be able to get nice reconstruction on
a lot of M's.
I think like practically what this could
end up looking like in puffer.
not too far off of what we have now,
right?
reasonable enough world model
architecture.
We fix up the losses so that the world
model trains way more stably.
We retune hypers.
This is at least somewhat encouraging in
that it's not
this is not a huge amount of compute,
right?
We are going to have to deal with the
reconstruction thing.
Okay, I'm going to just start copying
parameters over from uh this blue one,
and we're going to see if anything's
better by the time
we're done with this.
Uh, yes, Jess. Let me get this. Let me
finish just copying params over. Make
sure this benchmark works, and I'll push
it so you can get the latest.
It is pretty cool to be doing research
and having people um like live in real
time looking at stuff, you know.
Ah, this entropy is really low. That's
interesting.
Okay. Well, we've done a bunch of
experiments and
we got what seems like a decent
starting point.
If this repros
I'm just hoping this hyper is actually
repro.
Seems less stable though.
Start from here maybe.
change in state when an action is
performed.
Okay.
So, we should see based on this then if
um
the Leighton makes it better or not.
Uh, did we crash it?
We did. We crashed on the uh the
entropy.
How does that make any sense?
Nan's out on entropy.
I mean it was like basically we were
solving it and then we nan out on
entropy
very common
You probably do need like some more
explicit
like max ant formulation.
It's just so silly to me to be spending
so much time fiddling with such like
stupid toy trivial problems on um
you know like the paper's a it's the
best thing since sliced bread. Like you
should be able to just sneeze in the
general direction of this approach then
and have it at least do something.
Yeah. So that's I mean isn't but like
that's a problem, right?
Like for science to be that brittle is a
huge issue,
Like in Puffer, you actually just kind
of do the thing.
You mess with it a little and it just
works. Like you don't have to poke at
stuff a lot
before it just works.
Okay. So, there's some hyper pram
shenanigans here. There's some stability
shenanigans. There's some hyper pram
shenanigans, right?
Yeah, it's um
it's a problem.
Uh I did a quick hyperparameter sweep,
but like the problem is this data regime
is just less robust than what we're used
to doing with puffer.
But like you can get something where one
in three runs will work and then the
sweep will find that for instance.
Let me play with it for a little bit.
I'll get something to work
and then we'll see what we do from
There.
Yeah, it just crashes right at the end,
which is really weird. Oh, you know why?
cuz otherwise it shouldn't be able to
crash near the end of training.
Like the learning rates are all super
low.
policy should basically just be stable.
Nice. Look at that.
All right. That's like
That's not bad.
That's pong
close to solve in a million steps.
Let me commit this.
Okay,
now we have
Let's just uh
do we uh do we feel lucky here?
It's like very close to doing something,
but just it ain't there.
longer training
actual structure the ends
longer training period.
Um so it is actually right now it's
gathering
1,024 steps of data and then it's doing
six updates on 32k
samples for the world model and one
update on 32k samples for RL.
Kind of already doing this.
We can go try the latence though. the
latence thing.
or I guess it's
we don't really have
[Music]
Ricky. Okay.
Uh they just yeah they just spend a huge
amount of compute is the problem, right?
Like they'll literally spend they'll
spend three GPU hours on 100k samples.
What am I working on? I'm trying a
different a slightly different
model setup real quick.
I'm going to try a self-consistency
or like what is it? I'm going to try
dynamics loss. Yeah, that's what it is.
If he refreshes and gets to hang on the
winner more
max score
There more. I don't know what that
means.
Hang on. Let me get this thing
implemented.
Okay.
Well,
I might have been a little overeager on
this.
All right. So, here's what we're going
to do about this nonsense.
I think that all we have to do is we
just roll this back a tiny little bit,
right?
Screw up here.
Oh yeah, dummy.
Got it.
This should at least let us test, right?
Yeah. Okay. So, if this doesn't repro
the old thing
I mean, there are a couple like a couple
possible things I could have screwed up.
I just want to see if having a um
like predict next state loss does
anything.
I totally just freaking messed it up.
Unless, let me just see. MX,
if I comment this and it starts working.
I doubt it.
Huh,
that's weird.
Just having a dynamics loss breaks it.
Need to be more informative to build a
Mer model.
observations to solve a policy.
Uh, no, the observations are a full
representation of the world, Spencer.
This is the full information of the
game.
So, I I don't know if you saw, Spencer,
I got it to like almost solve. I got it
to 18 reward on Pong in under two
minutes with a million samples.
Like I actually got that to do
something.
Um I almost want to just redo and try
this again because I think I just
screwed up the dynamics.
You just make sure that adding a couple
layers is not breaking it.
This is like this version of it is
actually pretty stable.
Okay. Okay, so this should not make a
difference
Okay. So clearly right this is the same
as before.
And then all I'm going to do
is I'm going to add in
I'm going to add in the latent
prediction. Okay,
which is like this with a detach as
well.
And I'm just going to do plus dynamic
plus.
We're going to see if this breaks it or
not.
right. So, this is the exact same thing
as before with additional dynamics loss.
All right.
So, does having a dynamics loss break
everything?
why don't we go take a look at our fun
uh
other thing here.
Well, this experiment totally fails.
So, if I'm reading this correctly
though,
then literally it should just be that
commenting this
allows it to work, right?
Okay. Yeah. Dynamics loss breaks it.
Cool. You have to do reconstruction
apparently.
Am I doing something fundamentally
stupid with this
like this thing at least works and works
fast on Pong.
If I had this working like on breakout
in a couple minutes, then I'd be way
more excited.
Okay. So, here
we go back to our original horizon.
I almost don't understand how the heck
there is even any error in the world
model with the amount of data
like updates this thing is taking.
and this has also just completely
exhausted me this week.
I'm trying to think of any if there's
anything else I can do today that's like
useful on this
At least we're not on a freaking cart
pole. But like still.
Um, if you get the world model right,
this thing actually does scale with the
compute nicely.
whether it's stable for the whole time
or not.
course, it's going to give me 13 right
at the end.
Okay, let's let me then hang on.
Let me think of some stuff.
Let's do
And like
this work.
You can actually get
like some pretty crazy sample efficiency
out of this stuff.
Okay.
Promising, right?
is actually scaling with the compute
nicely.
and get like a 200k
200k benchmark.
it' be the same as just doing um
getting the data more slowly, right? So,
I would expect that there exist hypers
that solve this in um in 100k, All
right.
problem is that the uh the final PF
estimate you get is going to not be
good at all.
I guess I didn't expect this to scale so
well with the uh with compute.
I didn't expect to just be able to drop
the amount of data to almost nothing and
have it still work. So even though it's
a janky mess, it's like a mostly compute
limited janky mess. It's not like
it's not like really data limited at
all. It's kind of weird.
Yeah. Um
this is sweepable.
Yeah, breakout's still going to be a
problem.
I mean at least hey at least this is
progress because at least you know at
least I can see that even though the
method is a mess it does scale along the
dimension that it is supposed to scale
right which was not true before.
That's so weird how that actually does
stuff.
break out. Breakout working would be
cool. You have to get
you have to get like consistently above
eight or whatever, I'd say. But like
realistically, Breakout has um it's one
of those Ms where it takes a while to
get going and then it should learn very
quickly. So, like you should be able to
at least get some sort of reasonable
number of points.
Well, this didn't it didn't help to go
even lower on the data I'm using.
Uh
maybe
I mean, you can't have arbitrarily
little data, right?
So, I mean, that doesn't scale like
better enough to be worth it, but
that's nutty.
It is 3:26.
I'm trying to think if there's anything
I want to do today other than just run a
hyper sweep on Yes.
Well, the uh the problem I think kitting
is
that it doesn't scale like
it's not this nice smooth scaling thing
where you can use very little compute
and a ton of data or the other way
around because like
That's That's the one thing I'm not
happy with really.
So, we'll see if this intersects or if
this is actually just better the whole
time.
Tiny bit of sample reuse in a dumb way.
Huge amount of sample reuse.
It does seem actually like it's easier
with less data for this thing cuz the um
construction loss.
If I do,
actually, here's a quick experiment.
So, if I just say
that instead of 4 M's, we're going to
have
64 M's,
but I'm going to give you
Wait, that's times 16, right? But I'm
going to give you 2 million steps.
Actually, not bad.
Actually
That's actually a decent data scaling
thing, right? We just got um
Yeah, we just got a better policy. We
got a full solve out of that
in less time by using more data.
Does this work arbitrarily?
Can I do
G6?
There's a little bit of stability
shenanigans it seems if the data gets to
be too quick.
course, I haven't mixed this with online
RL yet.
Be right back. Let me use the restroom.
I didn't break this as well.
kind of curious.
Oh, you know what it is? Okay, there's a
4x difference. Then
this dreamer
I missed a scheduleuler update. Thank
you.
Uh, it says I didn't.
Wait, do you have the latest? It says
there's no death.
[Music]
Okay.
We're getting real data, though.
Reconstruction loss is slow.
same thing as puffer default except I
removed
Wait, what the heck? I removed actor
critic.
What?
my guy. Like
there's no way.
That's like a batshit like crazy
network.
That is like way way too deep for RL.
Oh, okay. That's a different story.
All
right. Well, we have a reconstruction
loss that's reasonable.
There's nothing fundamental here, right?
This is just a harder problem.
keeps looking like it's got it, but no,
it's just we're looking at noise
until we're getting like consistently.
Even 10 plus would be good.
All right. Chess on how might tackle it
the terminal reward and assign it across
all moves within a game. What?
No, you do you do advantage estimation,
right?
I'd probably do something where you give
like the score of the pieces or whatever
and then anneal that reward down to uh
just the win loss reward over training.
It's probably something like that would
work.
Yeah, that just like you need massive
massive scale for that because that like
you can't do credit assignment with
that. That's just like massive scale
required to actually learn any form of
credit assignment with that.
actually.
Um,
so Jess, you want to know something
funny with that? If you use reward of
one for all moves, then literally all
you're doing is you're running
behavioral cloning on the winning side.
So literally you're not even doing RL.
You're just doing behavioral cloning.
Isn't that funny?
All right. Come on. We have something
that solves pong now. And we can't get
anything
on breakout. Like really?
We have it running on uh Pong and we can
do pretty dang well on Pong in like 2
minutes with only 100,000 steps and
we've been not able to get anything
better than random on breakout. Speaking
of which,
experiments are too bloody long
there. Two-minut breakout experiment.
Good.
would you have a system that caches or
distills common state action patterns
updates quickly with reward
and biases the main policy.
Ah, so depending on the environment,
you're never going to see the same state
twice
and fuzzy state action mapping.
is exactly what RL does.
Breakout might just be harder to do with
only 16 horizon.
last one
and then I think I'm just going to
launch a sweep and we'll call it early
today.
I'd like to have some uh
some time to recover today
cuz basically I'm going to go
uh I got to go get myself a proper
dinner
and I got to get do some recovery stuff
because tomorrow morning bright and
early will be a run uh as far as I
possibly can and we'll See how far that
is. Last week was half marathon.
Hoping for
at least 15 miles this week.
Ideally more, but we'll see how I'm
feeling.
No. Downloading Runescape means that
there will be no future puffer versions.
No Runescape downloads allowed.
Uh then you wouldn't have remotely
enough data to cover that game.
We just implement a Runescape. And what
do you think the idea was for a neural
MMO?
like, yeah,
been there, done that.
We've got
this experiment to watch.
We've got that experiment to watch.
Still running.
We'll see whether this intersects and
gets closer or if this is actually like
just the best thing ever.
Wow. Well, those were the two big ones,
right?
Runescape is substantially better for RL
because how the servers are implemented
though.
It's like um
done correctly, you should get uh at
least like a 10 10x.
It should take like a tenth of the
compute basically for RS
done correctly. then for a while.
All right. Well, I mean, there's no use
in me just sitting here for the sake of
sitting here all day, right? Um,
I think I'm going to go do some stuff.
This is in like
I think if we can get good hypers on
Pong and then if I can at least see some
kind of initial result on Breakout,
then that's enough for this stuff to be
in like an okay spot, right?
There is such a massive compute
difference though.
Like we literally solve pong in 3
seconds with puffer
and now it's taking you know 2 minutes.
That's kind of the main issue.
There's the thing is until I find al
like unless I find an alternative though
this is basically the only thing I see
that makes sense
um
because like on policy RL is the only
thing that actually works and is fast
and you want to be able to reuse samples
and the buffer from a world model lets
you do that and the buffer from the
world model gives you like a more
flexible way to reuse those samples as
well.
And then the only main like question is
can you have is there like a con is
there a way you can parameterize
a world model based setup such that it
is
equal to onpaul RL if you give it enough
data
or can you just not do that
can do vision based M I suppose it's
just there well yeah they would still be
slower
because like you're seeing the SPS here
but you're not seeing the learn SPS like
because this is not 1.9K steps per
second trained uh that's like real data
samples the amount of hallucinated
samples
is like way way way higher than that.
Probably hundreds of millions.
Yeah. Because every time you're getting
what is this?
128 Every 128 samples that you get from
real data, you're training on 32,000
um hallucinated samples, right?
So yeah, it's like a totally different.
I'm going to go get some rest. I suggest
you all do the same. Um, if you're
interested in my stuff generally,
buffer.ai for all the things, start the
GitHub. It's free. Helps me out a ton.
You can follow me on Discord for more RL
content.
And
uh other way around. You can follow me
on Discord to get involved. And you can
join the Discord to get involved and
follow me on X for more RL content. Yep.
I need a night off. Gotcha. Oltopia and
when when you build it.
All right. Thank you folks. Uh, I will
see what I do for the rest of the day,
but get some